- Hello, I mean, congratulations
on all the awards.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, I mean, like, everybody
hasn't even seen it yet
and you're already winning awards.
That has to feel pretty fantastic.
- Oh, it's pretty cool, it's pretty cool.
- Yeah, yeah, so, okay.
So you play a very, even from that scene,
you can kind of tell a
very complex character.
It's kind of this
childhood's been taken away,
but you also have this awakening going on
as well as an adult.
How hard was that to play?
- I mean, it was a lot of work,
but Sammy's script, there was
so much in between the texts,
so I really just dove into it
and looked at certain parts of my life.
- I know, did you relate at all?
- Kind of a little bit, 'cause Joe,
at such a young age, he was a father,
so it was like this immense
sense of responsibility.
And I grew up an army brat,
so my dad was in the Army
and he served a few years in the war.
So I remember him sitting
me down when I was 11,
and he just gave me
this inspirational talk
about being a leader
and honor and integrity
and like taking care of my two
younger sisters and my mom.
He's my hero, so when he told
me that, I kind of stepped up
to the plate while he was away
and feeling is maybe similar
but different experience.
- Just having to grow up
a little quicker in a different way.
I think a lot of us, we go through that
in different family situations,
so that could be relatable.
But I heard that you also...
You had to eat, was it fast
food that you ate a lot of
to gain weight for the role?
- Yeah, I mean, I didn't have to eat it.
I kind of--
(laughter)
- They were like, you should
gain weight for the wrong,
you like ran to all the fast food.
- Yeah, no, Todd Haynes, our director,
we had conversations about
what Joe would feel like,
not so much look like.
And I was like, I think
this may be my opportunity.
He's a 36-year-old dad,
three kids, provider,
all this stuff.
Like, he doesn't have
time to go to the gym,
but maybe he has time to eat.
(laughter)
- This is my moment to
eat whatever I want.
- Yes, so I ate so much
pizza, fast food, ice cream.
- Nicely done, well, I heard
this is not your first
experience with fast food.
You actually worked fast
food when you were younger.
Okay, where'd you work?
So my first place was Arby's.
- Classic roast beef.
- Oh, amazing, they
used to have like the--
- With the Arby sauce.
- Yes, they used to have
like the five for five
for like 5.95 or something.
- Dude, I know.
- Yeah, it was amazing.
So I was there for six months.
After six months, I came home,
I told my dad, dad, I've learned so much
from just life behind the counter.
And I'm ready to--
- Move forward.
- I'm just ready to move
forward and thank you.
I'm gonna just focus in
school and everything.
- Thank you for this opportunity.
- Thank you, yeah. I'm a
sophomore in high school.
Like I'm ready to just...
Thank you, dad.
And he gets a phone call
and he was like, hey,
so your boss told me you got fired, yeah.
- You told him thank
you for the opportunity.
- And he was like, what happened?
And so me and one of my coworkers
after playing ice hockey
with brooms in the back--
- As you do.
- He threw a curly fry and I ducked
and the curly fry hit a customer
in the face and--
- Wait, you got fired for that?
Not even like a do better next time.
- So I turned in my notice and I left.
- Oh, you did turn in your notice?
I love you so much.
So wait, before we go,
quickly share you have a Wendy's hack.
I love your fast food stories.
- Another fast food story.
- What is your Wendy's hack, yeah.
- So my Wendy's hack because after Arby's,
my dad's like, we're going to Wendy's.
- Elevated.
- So we go there and yeah,
so I love working the cash register.
And there's so many
substitutions you can do.
So I can mix up, I can get a Baconator
and substitute like the pretzel bread
or the jalapeno cheddar
bread, or I can do like--
- You can do that?
- You can do that.
It's just like a matter of
how you communicate the order,
which I know.
And so they know how to...
There's like no complications at all.
They're just like, oh my gosh, thank you.
- You're making this so easy.
It's a dream client.
- Yeah, oh my gosh, you're great.
- Oh my God, I love how
different you are from your role
that you're playing in this movie.
You are a great actor.
You are so different from
this role, it's amazing.
I love you so much.
Let's do another commercial
break, everybody.
May December, which is
amazing, is now on Netflix.
You gotta check it out.